thank you very much indeed members I
welcome you to this extraordinary
meeting of the council this evening in
view of the fact that we've had a recess
and some people may have left on decent
meal may have joined us
I shall go through the usual procedures
for evacuation procedure if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices fire the stairs either through
the security doors to my right or
opposite the lifts in the foyer please
do not use the lifts please assemble in
Hawley square on the green officers will
assist you and advise when it is deemed
safe to return to the chamber webcasting
of proceedings the Proceedings of this
meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the Internet
filming of the meeting I would advise
that the filming takes place anyone in
attendance in the public areas may have
their image captured I urge anyone
filming proceedings to avoid filming
members of the public particularly if
there are children present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
and we have two I believe yes any member
of the public whose objects to the
possibility of being filmed may wish to
take this opportunity to leave the
meeting any filming or recording will
not be permitted for any item of
business where exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of press and public from the
meeting restriction on the use of mobile
phones with everyone present please
ensure that their mobile phone are
turned to silent and they are not used
to make or receive phone calls in the
chamber while this meeting is in
progress I will straight on to agenda
item 1 apologies for absence I have had
apologies from poor more counsellors
more and councillor Scott do I have any
other apologies please councillor Pugh
Thank You chair councillor Hart any
other apologies Chancellor Piper go to
the briefing chair any other apologies
thank you very much indeed
moving on to agenda item two
declarations of interests are there any
declarations of interest
evening I don't see any buddy indicating
agenda item three a notice of motion
over leader of the council
I call upon councillor Piper to put his
motion to council chairman could I just
ask for advice please from the legal
department members having read the
agenda will see that for example it says
members will be asked if they wish to
debate the matter and if they don't the
motion falls at that point I have been
advised that that is incorrect because
the motion we brought was that council
holds a vote of no confidence in the
current leader of Thanet District
Council and that can be done with or
without debate so could we please have
some clarity from the money officer I
pass you over to the monetary officer
yes thank you calcify but yes that is an
error so therefore therefore the Kumasi
can proceed whether or not it is debated
or not
counselor piped you wish to proceed with
your motion thank you chairman I may not
need the three minutes but could I have
my 13 seconds back please it's been
quite rightly pointed out among
individual members and also in the press
that the motion as we brought it that
council holds a vote of no confidence in
the current leader of Thanet district
council does leave the possibility of a
rather unsatisfactory outcome members
will by now be aware that were the
leader to lose the vote he wouldn't
necessarily have to go that would be
very unusual but he wouldn't necessarily
have to go so we would like to bring an
amendment to that motion adding the
words if the leader loses the vote of
no-confidence council resolves to remove
him from office so the full motion would
be that council holds a vote of no
confidence in the current leader of
Thanet District Council if the leader
loses the vote of no-confidence council
resolves to remove him from office we'd
like to bring the amendment please
Kathir Piper you can't bring an
amendment however you can bring an
alteration which I presume is your
intention here with that wording thank
you for that clarification chairman I
was following advice from the correct
department within the council but I will
accept your ruling
thank you very much indeed I must the
monetary officer would like to speak at
this point
yes I'm I don't believe that particular
motion met or alteration will be lawful
because you're making eight a
conditional vote as well so there should
only be one vote so I vote move with the
gems permission with the transmission
mr. Piper cacif I would like to approach
the chair to get advice on that
particular motion yes please yeah
counselor Piper are you ready with your
alteration German thank you I would like
advice to be given by the monitoring
officer on the conclusion that has been
reached and assurance that what I'm
about to read out would not in any way
adversely affect the ability to bring
the original substantive vote before
council counselor Piper you have been
here you have been at the top bench
you've spoken at length of the monetary
officer I did overhear what was said it
was very clear I'm not sure this very
much more he can add does he wish to
know so that the process now will be
canceled Piper will propose an
alteration and counsel then have a
choice you accept that alteration or not
a sec now what alteration if it doesn't
accept the alteration the original
motion becomes the main motion thank you
very much indeed councilor pipe but
would you like to proceed then Thank You
chairman and thank you to the monitoring
officer in advise through all to the
motion to read that council holds a vote
of no confidence in the current leader
of Thanet District Council and removes
him from office thank you Thank You
councillor Piper members there is the
alteration to the motion could I have a
vote those in favor those are against
the alteration council councilor yes
that are you you're voting please first
of all could I have those in favor of
the alteration
and those against the alteration
and can I have abstentions please I have
one abstention councillor Bailey
Casa Piper your alteration has been
included within the main motion would
you now like speak to your motion your
substantive motion Thank You mr. Gerron
there's an old naval tradition that the
captain always goes down with the ship
and history provides us with many
examples of extreme courage shown by
great leaders as the RMS Titanic drifted
in extra me towards her ultimate device
demise having received the fatal room
below decks the orchestra gathered on
the main deck and played nearer my God
to thee in that instant a group of
ordinary people showed extraordinary
courage and sacrificed their own desire
for personal survival in favor of
bringing comfort to others I don't
suppose it was easy I daresay most
people on the ship had no idea why it
was in so much trouble then gradually
the awful truth normal members the
inevitable panic set in
when realization the ship was
floundering out of control hit home a
tragedy that could not be avoided befell
the passengers and crew last spring a
group of politicians decided enough was
enough and the council leader owed then
a debt of honor to those who've elected
him and his team leader you know the
rest he eventually took the only
honorable way out and got into a
lifeboat you were gifted control of this
council and you set about steering the
ship your early promises were met the
local plan indeed went out for
consideration scene 3 making steady
progress in choppy waters the DCO
application by River Oak got the one
more chance it needed to try and save
the airport and bring jobs and an
economic future for chthonic one step
closer they did not support their
disappoint either they too seem to be
making good progress through choppy
waters it would be crass leader to
suggest you have had no success during
your term at the helm it would be
grossly unfair what would not be unfair
though to art is to ask what went wrong
it all started so well a bit like that
trip across the Atlantic Ocean in the
famous ship how sad it was to find out
many years later the ship was in fact
doomed before it left the port I'm not
here to trawl through a list of near
misses and ongoing hazards
I mean where I need to be very careful
about living alleging specific actions
or lack of others must decide for
themselves whether the list of ongoing
near-misses matter enough for them to
gather together to try and bring comfort
to others but leader you have made
promises you simply have not kept even
the feasibility study on the poor at
best is going to be later than you
promised these things have happened
while you've been watch commander on
this ship mortal blows have been struck
to the regular reputation of this
council and our biggest concern is that
you have failed in your duty to enhance
the reputation of this council among the
people we are here to serve I assure you
our concerns arise from within and not
from without this council but however
leave that what if they were we have no
right to pour scorn on people and their
voices and their influence outside this
council they have a voice which deserves
to be respected listen to and
communicated with at least the radio
operator aboard the carpathian was
listening even you bind up now counselor
away do any good in accordance with the
council procedure rule 3.7 a member of
the council yes first of all can I have
it have you got a second - councillor
Piper
councillor Potts
in accordance with the council procedure
rule 3.7 a member of the controlling
political group is entitled to reply I
call upon the leader chairman and I'm
bound to say that council Peiffer is
intact to his opinion and indeed this
council tonight will decide whether my
tenure as leader continues or stops what
I would say though is that I think that
criticism of this council but by and
large comes from a fairly narrow strata
of the Thanet community as a strata that
actually is led by somebody that puts up
some of the vilest things that I
ever seen appearing on Facebook and that
some people who don't actually examine
the truth of some of the things that are
included in there choose to believe I
don't believe that the vast majority of
people in Senate do actually think that
this council is in the state that you
think it is councillor Piper and in fact
what No I'm sorry that I do I honestly
believe that your actions tonight are
extraordinarily personal they're aimed
solely at me
and for reasons that I'm not quite sure
um I gave you the opportunity to
actually offer some stability to this
council which you chose to ignore right
the start of this thing yeah and now
absolutely did and the fact is that that
you know you chose not to do that so
we're in the situation we're in the
minority Council and as I said earlier
I've done my best where possible to
actually steer a course where as many
members can get involved as they
possibly gain the the fact is that this
is a really strange motion because
normally somebody moving a motion of no
confidence and the removal of the leader
is heading up a party that's seeking to
take control a patent that you can't do
that so your motive must be to either
choose the leader of this conservative
group or you wish to seek out forever as
leader of this council yeah I'd like to
know which one is most important to you
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed leader
yes point of order can monitor or
explain if this motion is successful who
then leads the council what process will
take place to determine who will lead
the council Thank You councillor
Campbell I turn to the monitoring
officer yes where the council to remove
the leader from office we would
immediately have to move to appointing a
new leader by vote at this meeting
two members wish to debate councilor
Piper's motion councillor Everett well
I'm grateful that we've had the
alteration to the motion and the labor
groups happy to debate that motion
because I have to say to council the
piper I've no idea why he brought the
motion in the form that he did and I
have no idea why he called an
extraordinary council to do it because
he could have done it and this evening's
ordinary council a motion of no
confidence on its own is neither here
nor there
what councilor Piper had tried to do was
arrange a showdown a shootout a high
noon with councilor beaufort but he
brought the water pistol now we have a
motion that we needed proper
consideration to but I do know that
councillor Piper had the opportunity to
choose this leader the leader of this
council in May when the vote was tied
between the myself and councilor
Playford and was decided on the casting
vote of the chair but councilor Piper's
group chose to sit on their hands I do
wonder about the motivation of some of
the people on councilor Beaufort's back
benches but that's not matter for me the
labor group does not want to play
political games with this council we
recognize the need for stability we will
vote tonight to replace councilor
Beauford because we believe that labor
has the policy and the people to make
this council work better for the people
of fanuc we also had the humility to
recognize that councils we also have the
humility to recognize that the council's
problems are not all about one person
the council faces formidable challenges
of which the biggest is deprivation
shortage of jobs shortage of homes and
yes streets that are too dirty in too
many places it also faces
crippling cuts in government funding
another reason why this council should
not be led by the Conservatives putting
labour in the driving seat can we
believe provide better leadership but it
won't solve everything if we run the
council we will do so in a collaborative
way because that's our instinct but also
because it's a necessity because of the
numbers
members can work that out for themselves
we will work closely with the green
councillors but we will work with every
councillor in every party because we
have all been elected by the residents
where I do support councillor Piper is
believing that Fanny deserves better so
I urge everyone to vote for change
tonight Thank You councillor Everett do
I have any other speakers this evening
councillor Yates Thank You Jay I'll be
brief as I can I do take exception that
only one spectrum of political parties
do not have confidence in the leader I
am quite a new counselor but councillor
Beaufort is a councillor of long
experience but he has let go of the
steering wheel in Margate central alone
which is from my experience as a new
counselor we have had the failings of
East Kent housing which I mentioned
tonight we've had the you turn over
firing multiple tourism tourist stuff
which is so critical to our local
tourist economy we have had the
one-pound rental of the harbour arm in
Margate we have had empty shop fronts
under Arlington House as tourists come
into Margate this could be stopped
because TDC has the right to enforce a
lease the states these shops must be
kept open and they're not doing that and
in this building alone we have
allegations and accusations of all sorts
and legal issues of which I allegations
which I won't go into but this this
needs to change thank you
Thank You councillor Yates does anyone
else wish to speak this evening
councillor Stevens yes so just will they
pick up on the point about stability and
I echo those thoughts it's desperately
what we need but we are in danger if we
go through with this of having a
six months yo-yo system where you know
if labor were to get voted in we could
then have another vote of no-confidence
and then it's hey it's our turn and I'm
not sure that actually benefits than it
as a whole I mean I take on board the
points that councilor was saying about
you know working collaboratively and
that is something that I've championed
even before I got elected so I feel
that's very important but I don't
necessarily obviously don't agree that
having a Labor Party is the solution
because we could be in exactly the same
boat in six months time and that worries
me enormous Lee isn't for me that's not
a political thing it's just a statement
that worries me for the good of the
community so you know I wanted to make
that point Thank You councillor game
thank you Thank You councillor Piper
first of all I wondered why he bought
this motion forward I did wonder whether
he'd fallen in love with labour
obviously he has I don't think they're
really in love with him but they will
use him I'm sure they will use him um I
actually believe that you're doing this
because external influences are
interfering here and I think that is
shameful I also think it's shameful for
you to criticize the leader as you do
and I wonder what illusions you've
suddenly got did you really think that
you've become you could become leader I
just say shame on you thank
councillor game councillor Constantine I
can't comment on the accounts of Piper's
motives but what I can say is that it is
going to be very difficult to achieve
stability in this council and the reason
it's going to be difficult to achieve
stability in this council is because of
the contact of cognitive dissonance and
we're living really through very hard
times created by austerity which is a
choice forced upon the local population
and forced upon every single councillor
in this room and I think what Labour can
do is I think we can manage the council
services better and I think we can point
out very clearly why we're in this mess
that we're in and what is that mess
it's absolutely filthy streets it's
absolutely overflowing bins especially
during the summer during the tourist
season it's about the homeless that we
see on the streets everywhere everywhere
you go any town any beach any street you
are seeing homeless people this is a
very sad indictment of both this council
but also about the jet the Tory
administration we've seen rough sleepers
people contacting you because they're
sleeping in the back of a car or
sleeping in a shed or sleeping in a tent
as I say a family of eight we've seen
the catastrophe of dangerous buildings
we can't go on like this this is why I
think labour will lead this council
better and Labour have to now be given
the opportunity to do that because we
will general genuinely put the residents
first and we will judge genuinely put
the workers of this council first as
well thank you very much councillor
shrub
[Applause]
thank you right can I just ask who has
the quality and knowledge the background
and the high level of experience in this
room to run the council as councilor
Byford put put your hand up if you think
you can do the job
Thank You counselor counselor Alvin yes
Thank You chair I don't wish to be
frivolous but if we're given a gift
horse we're not going to look at in the
mouth Thank You councillor Beaufort yeah
Thank You chairman
um I'm quite obvious why things are
going to go now but you know the fact is
that I sincerely hope if Labour do land
up in control here that they can do all
the things they say I've got to say that
when you actually look at the budget and
things that are available to you it then
you know well done what I have got just
come back you know because I'm sorry I
through belief this is personal I think
this is councillor Piper really you
haven't got me and I'd mind less if I
thought that it was him doing it from
his own volition
we know the operates solely at the beck
and call of his puppet master up in
Rancho and councillor Padre I'm sorry
regard regardless regardless of what
regardless of what happens to me I do
think that you are a disgrace to this
council and so for you to actually bring
about I think we need to calm down a bit
please everyone can we calm down a bit
thank you very much councillor Townend
yeah I'd like to echo thank you for
caring I'd like to echo counsel Stephens
approach the civility is now moved in
such a way there's going to be totally
no civility and is that what we're
actually trying to achieve tonight I
don't believe we are
I don't believe that the labor group
will I'd do any better than what we do
and I think that what we have achieved
over here we have achieved an awful lot
more stability than I think you ever
will thank you
Thank You counselor town and cancer wing
as a newly elected council I find all
this a bit shocking actually because we
stood on a platform of honest open
transparent politics and I was walked
into a lion's den actually and I'm
watching if I could make a sporty
nandana analogy to sumo wrestlers
fighting it out and that's not the world
what we should be doing fifty six of us
were elected by our residents
we're in extraordinary times that have
been inflicted upon us we're now in
double figures of austerity and I'm not
going to blame the parties because I
don't think it helps throwing mud at
each other what I'd like to see and and
and the Labour leader actually said we
will work with the greens that's not
gonna work just working with the Greens
the fifty sick of six fifty six of us
have got to represent our residents and
we've got to work together so that means
electing in my opinion or in our opinion
it means kind of politics it's not
throwing mud at each other in this room
which I find if you were a classroom of
half a dozen of you would be out of the
room already it means kind of politics
to each other and also to our residents
it means listening to each other it
means information coming to people so
that they can understand how decisions
are being made we need a strong leader I
don't really care who that where that
strong leader comes from what political
persuasion they are and that strong
leaders then got to have the courage and
I and I don't have the experience for
this but I can sort of see what's
happening as a minority group just sat
here they need the courage to to try and
bring together a coalition cabinet of
the strongest people in this room so
that if you get ourselves out of this
mess Thank You councillor Waring castle
Tomlinson Thank You chair it's very
unusual for me to stand up twice tonight
before council one I think what I'm
listening here you know I've been one of
the longer ones we have many new people
here tonight I'm not saying there isn't
a good thing we have a lot of new
younger people which again is an
excellent thing but here in what's going
on between professional men and here
think such disgrace absolute disgrace
it's been mentioned about alright
everyone knows how I love Marg a
privilege be the mayor of that town as
we have the mayor of Ramsgate here
tonight as well but hearing just now
about Margate seafront Arlington House
all the shops around it now all respect
to councillor over there has been here
two years
is it the cancer was fault this groups
fault that that is in such a state no
it's the people who own it and it's the
same it mention about buildings falling
down is that the council was fault the
Conservatives that that buildings
falling down did we know it now it's no
good Rob you're not in your head because
you haven't a clue I'm sorry I'm not
normally rude at all sorry chair but I'm
getting like other people getting rather
annoyed it can happen to the labor group
there's some lovely people I've got to
know over here over the years and I mean
that say me the conservative group we
should be working together it's not a
political organization that when a
building is tatty
yes course we can go along and say paint
it up but it doesn't belong to this
Authority and on many occasions we don't
have the authority to tell people to do
that sort of work Thank You chair and
Thank You councillor Tumnus and
councillor Ashby Thank You chair when
well where do I start
and all I can say is that this isn't a
vote of no-confidence or even removal of
the leader this is the removal of the
Conservative administration for this
council it sizzling that because that is
what will happen if it goes this way you
are handing the administration to labour
all I can say is I'm a very apolitical
person I am NOT I'm here
for the people that voted a thing and we
have worked sorry my cold-eeze
horrendous but we had worked very hard
in in the
time that I've been in cabinet and I can
vouch it for as a group and for the
cabinet it's been a very very hard work
and the last six eight weeks sorry six
eight weeks have been exceptionally
telling on certain members of the
cabinet here so all I can say is be
careful what you wish for Thank You
councillor Ashby councillor Piper would
you like to wind up please Thank You
chairman I'm gonna ignore the personal
insults because I didn't make any myself
and there's no value in that councillor
everett said collaborative working the
job of independent councillors is to
favor
neither one side nor the other but to
give people an honest opportunity to do
the best they can for the area which we
serve and the people who engage us so to
do rest assured echoing the thoughts of
councillor wing a simple statement well
we'll keep you in touch and so on isn't
going to cut it we will hold the Labour
group to that promise if they take over
this administration I did say our
concerns are from within I resent the
allegation that they're not and anyway
why shouldn't I trust these lovely
people that you so eloquently described
just now leader I am sorry but you have
not sought to show that you are in
control of this ship or even still at
the wheelhouse and you certainly don't
appear to be listening you it is who
could have saved the Conservative
administration if that's the way the
vote goes simply by resigning but you
chose not to do that this leader is
perhaps your own personal iceberg this
council is mortally though not yet
fatally wounded and the purpose of our
motion is to steady this ship we believe
you're not steering it you're standing
aboard a rudderless pontoons drifting on
the tide thank you Jim
you can sniff and I can't bring you back
in at this point in the debate we've had
the winding up I'd like to proceed to a
show of hands at the moment can I first
of all have all those who do not have
confidence in the leader please raise
your hands that is a substantive motion
yes clarify it is the original motion
with the alteration to remove the need
of Malthus
so the motion under consideration is as
follows that council holds the vote of
no confidence in the current leader of
Thanet District Council and removes the
leader from office right on that basis
can I have a show of hands all those who
do not have confidence in the leader
please raise your hand
and thank you very much all those who
have confidence in the leader please
raise your hand now
can I have abstentions one abstention
Cathal Bailey remembers that is carried
we now are in new territory
we do need nominations for leaders this
evening from groups could I have them
please
point of order comes with constant 29 40
and 20 against 22 again sorry 20 to 29
22 with one extent this abstention
councillor Campbell I nominate counselor
ever it for leader of the council and
seconded
councillor Alban councillor fanbridge I
was just wondering I was just wondering
if it's possible that you know like we
could have a delay on and that we could
actually sort of like speak to our group
to see if we could actually put up an a
leader here that maybe we could we had a
chance of actually winning this this
vote so we could continue our
administration no I think we're quite
ready to proceed actually thank you very
much councillor Ashby for leader
thank you very much councillor Ashby is
that seconded
thank you very much councillor game do I
have any other nominations for leader no
right can we proceed I'd like to
nominate and council Ashby counselor
Ashby do you wish to accept the
nomination councillor Ashby is
indicating that she does not wish to
accept the nomination councillor
bambridge would it be seconded
right okay so we got
councillor Ashby has turned down the
nomination so we are left with the two
candidates that we started with we can
proceed now on the basis could I have a
show of hands encounter favor councillor
Everett
thank you very much can I have a show of
hands in favor councillor BAE furred
can I have abstentions please thank you
two abstentions
members we have a new leader councillor
everett is now leader of the council and
the number Casa effort would you like to
appoint your deputy leader council he'll
my head thank you very much indeed
I believe councillor Beaufort you'd like
to finish with a few words
yeah Thank You chairman and I'd like to
thank members for the haven't had the
opportunity to lead this case at the
time that I did and I genuinely wish
councillor every good luck because he's
going to need it that's for sure and I
do fear for the ongoing stability of
this counts I really do hope I'm wrong
but I don't think I will be and given
some of the people in this chamber
councillor Everett chair I'd like to
thank Council by Forest Service as
leader of this council and the deters
leader the conservative group over many
years we haven't always seen eye to eye
but I think that we've had an amicable
relationship over most of that on when I
first came to this council there was a
real level of personal hostility between
the labor front bench and the
conservative front bench which I think
was thoroughly unhealthy and I don't
think that's the situation today and I
hope it won't become the situation as a
result what's happened this evening the
labor group did not bring this motion
because we recognize that we have 20
members it is difficult for us to run
this council but at the same time we
could not come here as councillors
representing the Labour Party and not
put ourselves forward to take over the
leadership when given the opportunity so
I understand all the things that have
been said this is not a scheme that we
have concocted with councillor Piper or
or other groups this is where we are
tonight we will try to work as
collaborative as collaboratively as we
can
with every member of this council
whatever group they were in and as I
said I think the model tonight of the
corporate objectives was an outstanding
success that we work together on and I
look forward to the labor group working
with the conservative front bench as
well as all the other councillors in
this chamber but the good of the people
of Fannie we won't always get it right
but we will try our best
thank you very much councillor efforts
that concludes the business of this
council this evening thank you very much
to all members for attending